Kuei, bienvenue à Parole autochtone,
ici c'est Melissa Mollen Dupuis.
Cette semaine, je réponds à une question
de Réjean qui me demande :
« Pourquoi la Ville de Montréal a-t-elle mis
un pin au centre de son drapeau? »
Réjean, le 13 septembre 2017, c'était la journée
de célébration de la Déclaration des droits des peuples
autochtones des Nations unies.
Et cette journée-là, la Ville de Montréal
a dévoilé le drapeau qu'on voit
maintenant avec un pin au milieu.
Ça venait compléter les autres emblèmes
qui représentent les différentes nations
qui ont créé, dans le fond, la ville
de Montréal. Pourquoi le pin blanc?
C'est qu'à une certaine époque,
avant l'arrivée des Européens,
la légende de la création de la Terre
impliquait le pin blanc et le pin blanc,
c'est un arbre qu'on voit comme l'arbre de vie,
l'arbre de la médecine chez les Mohawks.
Et donc, en l'honneur de la nation mohawk
qui est encore située autour
de l'île de Montréal,
malheureusement plus sur l'île,
puisqu'ils ont été repoussées
en dehors du territoire,
on a mis un pin blanc au centre du drapeau.
Ce qui, selon moi, était vraiment
fantastique, parce que plutôt que
d'essayer de le mettre dans un recoin,
on l'a mis central pour représenter
vraiment l'importance de la culture
des Mohawks sur le territoire de l'île
de Montréal et dans ces régions.
Donc la question, Réjean,
elle est très bonne et j'espère que ça
va vous intéresser d'aller explorer
les légendes de création de la nation mohawk,
justement ceux qui vivent
à Montréal, particulièrement.
J'espère d'ailleurs que vous allez
partager cette vidéo et que vous n'allez
pas hésiter à nous envoyer vos questions.
Je vous souhaite une belle semaine.